so the real tried-and-true theme of the
Trump presidency is Magga except it
stands for making attorneys get
attorneys and rudy giuliani is now
starting speculation that he may be
getting ready to turn on Donald Trump
and to tell the whole story as the walls
are closing in on him he has now hired
three lawyers to defend him as the
Ukraine scandal has pushed Rudy's
corruption into the forefront once again
so listen we don't know yet whether Rudy
Giuliani is doing this in preparation to
turn on Trump or not but it is certainly
looking more and more like that's a real
possibility especially with multiple of
Rudy's own associates getting themselves
arrested about to leave the country on
one-way tickets to Europe quick reminder
former New York City Mayor Rudy Giuliani
has been Donald Trump's lawyer for some
time now but really he's a TV lawyer and
I've talked about this before Rudy
Giuliani is not Donald Trump's lawyer in
the sense that he's the guy doing the
legal work and filing the motions and
trying cases he's a lawyer who is really
functioning as a lobbyist and PR man an
influence peddler he plays Trump's
defender on TV he plays Trump's defender
in the media more broadly he makes
connections he peddles influence that's
what he does
but he has a law degree and at one point
was a and functioning attorney it's not
uncommon by the way that people who
worked as attorneys effectively become
lobbyists and influence peddlers but
still are attorneys in name in that
command some level of respect and
credibility now it turns out that Rudy
is up to his eyeballs in the corruption
and sketchiness around the Ukraine
situation he's traveling all over the
world he's pushing all sorts of foreign
diplomats and leaders to smear Joe Biden
to investigate from political opponents
so who knows what criminal acts Rudy may
have committed or directed committed by
others so now after two of his
associates were arrested on campaign
finance charges and the impeachment
inquiry is heating up with Rudy Giuliani
as one of the main people that
investigators will want to talk to Rudy
has hired numerous attorneys three
according to a bunch of different
reports about what's going on here now
it's important to understand that rudy
giuliani is a total total Trump
sycophants but in the end I believe Rudy
Giuliani is not someone with undying
loyalty to Donald Trump in fact it seems
most people at some point their loyalty
to Donald Trump runs out Rudy's name was
mentioned 68 times during bill Taylor's
recent testimony about the Ukraine
fiasco under oath Rudy has been making
it more and more clear that he will
continue making unhinged and outrageous
claims about Donald Trump's involvement
with Ukraine each claim less believable
than the last and I don't think it's
unreasonable that if and when it gets
right down to it Rudy will sing for the
purposes of self-preservation
this is not some random staffer who was
a coffee boy this is also not some
random staffer who was not a coffee boy
but Trump can claim was just a coffee
boy there are certain people who have
the goods on Trump if anyone does Rudy
Giuliani would be very very high on that
list now there's another element to this
Rudy may not deliberately turn on Trump
but he might inadvertently implicate
Trump or implicate himself in crimes
because he's done this before on Twitter
I won okay there's others more recent
but I remember when Rudy was being
interviewed I believe it was by Sean
Hannity before it had publicly been
admitted that the hush money given to
stormy Daniels even though it came from
Michael Cohen it really was Trump who
did that right it was Trump's payment he
paid through Michael Cohen before they
publicly admitted it Rudy Giuliani went
on and blurted out that actually that is
what happened it turns out that wasn't
public yet even though any reasonable
and reasonable person of course believed
that that was the case but Rudy
sometimes can't help himself so this
could be a very interesting couple of
months for Rudy Giuliani we will of
course be watching it and my question to
you is if you had to predict it today
where will Rudy be in two months
will he be will he have turned state's
witness will he have become not maybe
state is the wrong term here but will he
become someone who is a witness in favor
of Trump's impeachment for the House of
Representatives will he simply have
faded
as he did for about a six-month period
after bungling a bunch of television
appearances in the lead-up to the
release of the Moller report where do
you think Rudy will be two months from
now what will we know about Rudy
Giuliani in two months let me know by if
you're watching on YouTube leave a
comment down below otherwise send me a
tweet at D Pakman on Twitter